And the answer is 0.0079.
In other words, there's only 0.79% chance,
0.79 out of 100 that, despite the positive test result,
that you have cancer. And we're going to apply
the exact same mechanics as we did before.
The result of Bayes Rule, non-normalized of C given POS
is simply the product of my prior probability, 0.001 times 0.8,
which is the probability of a positive result in the cancer state.
And that ends up to be 0.0008.
The non-normalized probability for the opposite event,
the non-cancerous event, given a positive test,
is 0.999 times 0.1. And that's obviously 0.0999.
Our normalizer is the sum of both of those, which is 0.1007
just add these two values up over here.
So dividing 0.0008, the non-normalized probability,
by 0.1007 gives us 0.0079.
We just applied Bayes Rule to compute a really involved
probability of having cancer after seeing a test result.